[Applause]  Oh need help sir  Oh officer hi you need help no no I'm  fine thank you  but he got there the pecans i delivering  pecans to my niece in syria  yeah we can she makes it worst pecan pie  you've ever tasted I feel sorry for her  husband but n I feel sorry for pecan  family's the most important thing don't  do what I did I could work in front of  family I thought it was more important  to be somebody out there then the D I'm  failure I was in my own home  [Music]  was a terrible father  terrible husband  blew my chance  [Music]  I didn't deserve forgiveness  this is the last one  so help me  this is the last one  so what it's worth I'm sorry for  everything  [Music]  you